But now we have problem. We got 0 for our average deviation, and that's can't be
a good measure of how spread out these are. I would think that, if we had the
same data point over and over again that the spread of this would be 0. But here
we have a lot of data points all over the number line and there's got to be some
kind of spread there. So this can't be our measure of spread, if we're going to
get 0. The problem is that the negatives are cancelling out the positives. When
measuring spread, we don't care if our data values are above or below the mean.
We just care how far they are from the mean. So how can we make sure that the
positive and negative deviations don't cancel each other out? Choose all that
you think could work. Ignore the negative sign, at least for those with negative
deviations. Multiply each deviation by 2. Square each deviation. In other words,
multiply each deviation by itself, or is there nothing we can do? But first,
this is very tricky, please think hard about this because measuring spread is
crucial to statistics. Good luck.